Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're gonna talk about some
of your most embarrassing
holiday memories.
'Cause we thought, you know what?
The holidays are strange
this year and strained.
I mean, a lot of plans
that have been altered
or canceled altogether.
I mean, as we've discussed,
neither one of us are
going home for the holidays
because of the pandemic
and all the unknowns.
And so we're sitting here in
this weird holiday experience,
different from any we've ever had.
And I just thought it would be fun
to talk about embarrassing things
that have happened over the holidays
so then we could at least say,
if you're not going home,
if you're not seeing your loved ones,
you could at least be like,
well, at least the chances
of something that embarrassing happening
have gone down drastically.
Well, I mean, I don't know.
I can embarrass myself in front
of my own immediate family.
I guess it is harder to do though.
Especially, depending on what
kind of family you go home to,
like, if you are like a new spouse,
which we've got a couple
of those situations,
going home for Christmas
with your new spouse
for the first time,
or you're just like a
new boyfriend/girlfriend
kind of thing.
I think that's where
there's the most potential
for embarrassment.
'Cause you're entering
into an unknown situation
and you don't know how
they're gonna treat you,
don't know what kind of
things they're gonna say.
I mean, what kind of environment
are you walking into?
Are you gonna say the wrong thing?
Are you gonna look at
somebody the wrong way?
Are you not gonna understand Uncle Barry?
Uncle Barry.
You know, you don't have to
worry about that this year.
Yeah, that's so long ago for us.
I can barely remember
just getting to know,
like before they were my in-laws,
like going in on Christmas
with them or whatever.
Me especially.
But it was
a high pressure situation.
But you too.
I had a whole lot of interaction
with my wife's family,
even before we started dating, really,
because that's how I got to know Jessie
was by knowing her family first.
So it was a little bit less of a,
and definitely by the
time we were married,
it was like.
It wasn't pressurized.
Yes, actually we lived above their garage.
That's right.
In that little one bedroom
with a slanting roof that I had to duck
just to walk around up there.
We grew up around our
families, like whenever,
Christy started being
introduced to my family.
It was like, that was
more of a dating thing
than a holiday thing,
because we all lived in
relatively the same area,
but for other people, yeah.
It's like introducing someone
to your significant other
for the first time happens
a lot around the holidays.
We also weren't.
I mean, as different
as your family might be
from your wife's family,
or my family might be
from my wife's family,
we're still all a bunch of
people from North Carolina.
Like, it's not like you're going
to a whole different culture
or something like that.
So it was like,
I kinda know what I'm getting
myself into here, right?
Well, before we get into
those stories though,
I have an embarrassing story
that I already told you,
but now I'm gonna tell everybody.
Everybody needs to hear this.
It's not embarrassing for me.
It's not really a holiday
story either, but.
It felt a little embarrassed
when you share the full
extent of it with me.
Okay. Well.
But let them have it.
Yesterday, as a matter
of fact, this happened.
We're recording this on
a Monday and yesterday,
I took the boys, my two sons,
Locke and Shepherd on a Sunday drive.
Now, you've been doing
some family driving,
and you've talked about
that during the pandemic.
Early on in quarantine, it
was like, you know what?
We're just gonna drive around.
We're gonna see what's
happening or not happening,
but we're not gonna get out of the car.
We're gonna stay in the safety of our car.
That kind of trickled off after a while.
And I was just like,
I'm gonna take the boys,
kind of get them out.
And, you know, there was
like, talk of going surfing.
Trickled off is a little
foreshadowing for you.
We were talking about maybe
like going to the beach
or going surfing, but we're
like, what if we just drove?
And we stopped at a bunch
of places and, you know,
we've got one of the most famous drives
that you can do in the
entire world is the PCH.
And it's right here.
We can just get on it.
The Pacific Coast Highway
is what that stands for.
This is the highway that
goes right up the coast.
The one.
I had never eaten at this
place called Neptune's Net,
which is the place-
I haven't either.
It's pretty far North.
It's County Line Beach.
So all the way at the County line between-
Oh, above Malibu.
Yeah. I mean, like, if you're-
Oh, you went way up there.
Well, that was the whole idea.
We were gonna drive all the way to Oxnard.
See what Oxnard's all about.
You know, it's kind of a weird name.
And I've always kinda
been interested in, like,
what's going over here,
what's on what's happening
in Oxnard and Ventura,
but we never make it out that way.
And I had had intentions
of eating at Neptune's Net,
for some time, but of course, you know,
with COVID and everything,
wasn't making my way down there,
but I go online and there's
like a drive-through situation.
And let me tell you,
not that Neptune's Net
needs any more business,
because it was, it was very busy,
but they have it figured out.
What do you mean? Is it
like a fried seafood place?
I think that they are probably most known
for their fried seafood, but
they also have grilled seafood.
Fish tacos, hamburgers, lots of things.
But they got the drive-thru
COVID thing figured out?
Very well. They have some outdoor seating,
which we didn't do. We were just like,
we're gonna do the drive-through
thing and maybe like eat
in the car, you know, safety first.
I'm always on the fence
about fish and chips
I don't want to talk about fish and chips.
I want to talk about what happened.
I know, but I gotta say this
though, I gotta say this man.
They got- if you have are on
the fence about fish and chips
like I was, this will
completely redeem it.
So that was our first stop
driving all the way up Malibu.
And we stop at Neptune's Net,
go through the drive through,
get our food, eat it in the car.
And then we're like, alright,
let's take a little
stroll down to the beach.
Let's go down to the beach and okay.
I'm premising this with letting you know,
I'm not a braggy daddy, but I own a Tesla.
That is the car that I drive.
If you remember The Society,
you've seen me drive it
in some of the carpool vlogs.
But I have to say that by
way of setting the context
for why what happened, happened.
So Tesla has this thing
called sentry mode,
which is, there's cameras on the car,
and you can have it set so
that when you leave the car
and it knows you left the car
because your phone is the
key to the car, right?
And so when you get away,
you walk away from the car,
the car locks and it automatically
goes into sentry mode,
which is it is recording everything
that is happening around your car.
So if somebody comes up and-
All the cameras that are
used to help it navigate
and know, Oh, you're passing a pedestrian
or another car is in your blind spot.
Or like when you drive your car,
it shows trash cans on
the side of the road.
I actually don't think
that that's using it.
I think it's using the cameras
and maybe like some sort
of LIDAR or something.
Okay. But the camera's
everywhere for like-
Backing up and maneuvering it.
But they're constantly recording.
There's a camera in the front,
camera in the back and then
two cameras on the sides.
And so what it'll do, if
somebody comes up to the car,
it actually, if you get close to the car,
when it's in sentry mode,
if you happen to look inside the car
and you see this big screen,
it'll say "sentry mode,
you are being recorded"
or something like that.
Like it lets you know, so
people who are like trying
to break in, "Oh, crap,
I'm being recorded."
And you have to hook a
hard drive up to your car.
Like a little USB hard drive
is like in the console.
So then when you come back to the car,
it says "14 sentry mode events recorded,"
and then you go and you
watch them, if you so please,
So we're walking on the beach
and I get an alert on my phone,
"sentry recording initiated'
or something like that.
Uh oh.
And then it was like
"car alarm initiated,"
which has never happened, you know?
In the whole time I've owned the car.
Could you stop it?
Or what did you do? Did
you run back to the car?
No. Cause I was like,
this is probably just-
you can't like look into that.
It's not like a Nest
cam where you can like,
look and see what the car is
recording from your phone.
I was just like, this is
probably one of those-
There's so many motorcycles on the PCH
and lots of loud
motorcycles. And I was like,
this is probably just a
loud motorcycle going by
and setting the alarm off.
Cause I had seen so many, so I didn't-
we kept walking around.
And then we'd go back to the car
and you can bring up the files,
and there's a little red
dot on the, you know,
you can scroll to the red dot
to see what the event was.
And so we just like, okay,
there's like 15 events recorded.
I'm like, let's see what
set the car alarm off.
And we were kind of doing it
just to have fun, you know,
showing the boys like how this works.
And so we kind of go through,
most of it is just people
walking past the car
is what set the little
red dot off. And then, Oh,
here's where the car
alarm went off. Oh yes.
It was a giant Harley that went by,
like just set it off, you know?
Wow.
But then there's this other
event and we scroll to it
and, now this is giving me an idea.
The camera, it's like the camera
is in the rear view mirror
and it's showing you like
the length of the car.
I would call it a blind spot mirror.
Like it's shooting like past the car
where a car would be in your blind spot.
So if someone comes and
stands next to your car,
you see their entire body.
But the camera is really
kind of focused right
on their midsection, which is important.
Yeah. Or like where,
where you would aim a
camera if someone were
in a car driving.
In the middle of the body.
Car level.
Now, in addition to people on motorcycles,
there's lots of people on bicycles.
And we say, Oh, there's an older man.
You know, who's been riding
a bicycle, he's got the full,
like bike gear on and the helmet.
And he walks right up to our car,
looks over his shoulder
and then whips it out.
And by "it", I mean his penis.
Why do you gotta say it like that?
Wiener man. Say his Wiener,
His Wiener.
And proceeds to urinate.
And it's one of those things.
That once you start seeing
it, you can't, it's not like,
I mean, we just,
me and the boys just start
laughing hysterically
Well, let me tell you.
Rhett played this video for me.
I wouldn't say that I was
begging to see it, but.
But I didn't tell you what
you were about to see.
You didn't describe like the composite
of the shot to the point where you've just
described it to everyone listening now.
And I would, I mean,
just picture if you needed
to pee and there was a webcam
at like groin level and you just walked,
you walked up to it and
peed right next to it.
I mean, like, hips
squared up to the camera.
Just like it wasn't
like, Oh, I can see this.
I can tell this guy's peeing,
and he's peeing like
away from me or a profile
He was a peeing away from everything else,
except the camera.
He was peeing basically
right towards the camera.
Right, but he was peeing away
from like the road and the people.
I mean, he was like, he was
parallel with the road, I guess.
He didn't turn away. Which is,
it's almost like he knew how Tesla's work.
But I don't think that he does.
I don't think he did,
But you should know this.
He had no pee fright. Yeah.
It was just like there it
was and then here it comes.
And I completely understand
when you're biking down the PCH,
you got to stop. Right. And
this is what you're gonna do.
You're gonna go on the side.
They're just like people
who get finished surfing
and they just pee on the side
of the road. It happens often.
I mean, I don't have anything
against the guy for doing it,
but I'm just saying-
I just don't know why we
sat there and watched.
It's like, once you know what's happening,
we didn't just stop while
we watched the whole event.
Well, it didn't last
that long because I mean,
it was pretty short. He must
have stopped quite a bit.
It was maybe seven seconds total.
It was crazy, man.
My boys got the biggest
kick out of it because,
you know, first of all,
they kept just talking about how great
of a day they were having.
They were like, "we got
to do this more often."
Oh, that's good.
But then when they would talk about
what they would remember,
they'd be like, well,
the main thing we're gonna remember is
that old man peeing on the camera.
He didn't, the pee
didn't go on the camera.
No, but he peed on camera.
He didn't pee on the camera.
Squared right up to it, man.
I mean it couldn't have been,
it couldn't have been
more fortuitously framed.
Well, here's the thing.
I think this serves as a warning, right?
No, of course.
I'm not, you know, I'm
not gonna, I mean that,
that footage lives on my hard drive,
which I guess I will delete it.
But for the video version,
we're cutting to it.
Yeah right.
Yeah, we're not.
We're obviously not sharing that.
Although, I mean, he did,
it was a public urination situation.
That's illegal.
You're technically not
supposed to do that.
And of course I didn't film him.
There was no permission
involved. It was just,
you do this next to my car
and my car records things.
I don't know what the
legalities of that are.
I, you know,
I would give him high marks
for his post-shaking regimen.
Like he had a very rigorous-
He ended with a very rigorous shake.
Well, he's about to get back on a bike.
I was afraid it was gonna
fall off for a second there,
It was very rigorous.
Let this be a warning.
The shaking.
If you've got to urinate
in public, I mean,
first of all, maybe find a different way.
What's the frame rate of your camera?
Can we slow that down?
I am not watching it again, okay?
Yes, you are.
No, I'm not.
Come on, man.
Do not do it next to a Tesla.
I'm sure more cars have this feature,
but just so you know, Teslas,
they all got this feature.
Now, whether or not somebody
has got it turned on or not.
I mean, I think why not turn it on?
Let's not use the phrase turned on.
And just don't do it.
If you're gonna pee next to a Tesla,
face away from the Tesla.
Don't like get parallel and
like pee towards the mirror
because there's a camera in
there, right there, right there.
Yeah. Right there.
Waist level.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, it's gonna be hard
to forget that. Thank you.
Thank you for sharing.
I mean, I think we probably
just saved some people a lot of heartache.
You know, people are like, I got pee.
Go pee next to an old car.
You know what I'm saying?
Just pee next to an old
car, the older the car,
the safer it is to pee next to it.
Oh, man. Yeah. That's embarrassing.
I was embarrassed to be
watching that, but it's over.
It's over.
You know what? I didn't do anything wrong.
No one did anything wrong.
Well, he did it something illegal.
I mean, yeah, okay.
All right, so we're gonna get
into your embarrassing stories.
We're gonna react to those.
See what's shaking on your front.
Oh God.
I didn't mean it like that.
Really? Shaking on your front?
I kind of meant it that way.
But I was like, "What's
shaking on the home front?"
"What's shaking on your
front?" is not even a saying.
No, it's not.
I was trying to make it work.
But first, we are gonna let you know
that over at mythical.com,
our website that has a store,
we sell a mask, the Mythical neon mask.
It's really a black
mask with neon writing.
Yeah, we call it the neon mask.
It's not a neon mask.
Black mask with neon text
doesn't roll off the tongue as much.
It's got a great fit to it.
You know, you've got
to get the right ones.
It's got the filters that you
can put inside of them, too.
Like the carbon or
whatever it is, you know.
Get that or whatever else
it is that you would want
from mythical.com. Rep your boys.
My aunt TC, she texted me.
And she was like, "I
love how your shirts feel
that you sell on your website.
I'd like to get a few more of those."
And I was like, okay,
just tell me your size.
And I shipped her some and
she got them this morning.
What did she order?
She sent me a voicemail.
Well, she didn't order specific ones.
I just told Jenna to pick out some
that she thought would be aunt-worthy.
Okay. Got it.
And then she just sent them.
So I don't even know what
she got specifically.
Cause it's not shipped
from here. You know,
it's shipped from the warehouse.
She said that she went through Sam's club
and I'm sure she was masked up and safe.
But some employee there
said, "I love your shirt."
And she was like, yep.
Yeah. Well that's my nephew.
And she was like, which one?
And she was like Link. She was like, well,
I watch everything they do.
That was the conversation.
Somebody had an aunt Vicky sighting.
Not aunt Vicky, aunt TC.
Aunt TC.
Yeah, aunt TC.
Okay. The story makes a little
more sense all of a sudden.
Why? Because aunt Vicky
wouldn't go to Sam's?
No, I just don't-
Vicky's not asking for
merch. TC's asking for merch.
Right, that's the part.
She likes the feel of it,
but she was also wanting
to rep her nephew,
repping your boys. You know,
it leads to conversations.
You connect with mythical
beasts out there in the wild.
That's what it's all about.
That and us making a
little bit of scratch.
Yeah.
Everybody wins mythical.com.
Let's start with a story.
Yes, Holly at hollysum the number 1.
Someone.
Someone, hollysum1.
"I introduced my boyfriend, James,
to my family by the wrong name.
In my defense, I had just
told him my cousin's name
is Jackson, so that was fresh in my brain.
At least they start with
the same two letters.
Yeah. So yeah, we're in this place
where you bringing your
significant other home,
they're meeting family
members for the first time.
If you can't get their name right,
that is quite embarrassing.
The question is, how long did this go on?
Was this a, "I would like
you guys to meet Jackson.
I mean, silly me, James."
Or was it, "I would like
you to meet Jackson"
and then just letting it sit for a while?
And then he has to be like,
"yeah, actually, it's James."
Because that's more embarrassing
if he had to clarify.
And that information is not available.
We do not have that
information. It's not available.
I choose to believe it
was really the latter.
Like she forgot his name forever.
Now I have name fright. It's
the type of thing that like,
once you start to believe
that you're gonna get
somebody's name wrong,
then you will start to
get people's names wrong.
There's like some psychological
downward spiral that I just,
I thought that naming it and
being more honest about it
and public with it would help.
But you couldn't remember
the name to name it.
But it doesn't.
It's not helping that
much. Like, you know what,
occasionally over the course
of the job that we do,
we have to say people's names.
Like it could be at a guest on our show,
or if we're giving a shout out to somebody
or something or other, or
just referring to somebody.
And if pronunciations are are difficult,
then that plays into my name fright, too.
Okay, this is how you
say this person's name.
You got to get it right. And this is like,
the more I concentrate
on getting it right,
the more I will get it wrong.
And I just know it's gonna happen.
It's like a self-sabotage.
Do you remember? We're
not gonna name any names,
but that happened to me.
That happened to me on an episode of GMM.
I'm not gonna tell you when it was.
Oh, yeah, a guest.
We had a guest and this
person's last name wasn't
necessarily straightforward, you know?
And it seems like there
was a couple of ways
you could go with it.
And of course, we make sure
that we know how to
pronounce everybody's names.
So someone came and told me,
this is how you say their name.
And so I was like, really
concentrating on like, okay,
this is how you say it.
This is how you say it.
And then we were doing our little opener
where we introduced the person.
And not only did I say the name wrong,
which I said it the way
that I was told to say it,
in my defense, but it
was wrong. And then also-
So you did say what you practiced.
I said, what I practiced,
but then I also said the name of the thing
that they were promoting
wrong because it was wrong.
That information was also wrong.
So this wasn't my fault, but I kind of,
and then she or he-
We were in the middle of the show.
Immediately. Well, we had
to cut to go into title.
And so this person was like, by the way,
it's so-and-so and this
thing is so-and-so,
you know, I was like, ah, man.
And this person was gracious at the time,
but it's one of those things
that you just immediately
are like, Oh man,
now that's the only thing I
can think about is the fact
that I got those two things wrong.
Yeah.
And I like saying people's names right
'cause it makes them feel good.
But then when you say it
wrong, it's like, you know,
you're just another person
who said their name wrong.
It's like, you don't
want to be that person.
Well, does this extend-?
To people you're dating?
You should probably get their names right.
For you, does it extend to like family?
Not family members, but okay.
Somebody has a new baby in your family.
Like you got a new nephew or new niece
or something like that.
I mean, does name fright
extend into those situations?
I can't think of-
Can't think of your
nieces' and nephews' names?
A specific example.
It depends. There's a little bit of that.
Yeah. I don't know if that's
happening with me yet.
But if you're dating somebody,
you just gotta get it straight.
Let's ask another one.
Clumsy Christmas.
That's like the subtitle
that I put on that one.
From Hecate. Is that
how you would say that?
I mean, htyson12.
Yeah, Hecate.
"Getting so drunk at my brother's
ugly Christmas sweater party,
I fell down the stairs inside the house
in front of no less than 25
people and broke my coccyx."
Oh, the tailbone.
"Spent the next few
months having to sit on a
special pillow at work.
And people thought I had
hemorrhoids and not a broken ass."
I mean, so hemorrhoids
are more embarrassing
than getting drunk and busting your ass.
Well, it's more drawn out.
Come on.
It's more drawn out if people think
you have hemorrhoids for a long time.
I mean, even if no one's watching,
like falling on your butt,
like breaking your coccyx,
like the end of your
spine, it hurts so bad.
Did you actually break the coccyx
when you broke your pelvis?
No.
You just bruised it or
was it not involved?
I mean, I hit,
it's just one of the rings busted
and you can either hit the
rings the bottom of your pelvis,
or you can, I guess
you can hit the coccyx.
There was someone else we know,
maybe somebody who worked here,
was it a family member that
like broke their coccyx?
When you land on that
thing, it's just like,
it's that type of pain that
there's nothing you can do.
It's just, your body freezes.
And you're just like, I'm in so much pain.
I can't do anything because
this is gonna last forever.
And every millisecond is like an eternity.
And it's very particular to
this busting your butt issue,
There's few things that hurt in that way.
But in the context of being, first of all,
being drunk helps with pain,
but it might actually help
with the embarrassment.
But think about how,
like you would immediately
try to like walk that off,
depending on the kind of person you are.
Some people get hurt and gather a crowd
and some people get hurt and say, ah,
I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm
actually dying, but I'm okay.
It's like a dog going somewhere,
going underneath the house to die.
The thing that this brings
to mind for me though,
is the threshold of a size
of a party in which you can
comfortably get too,
you can drink too much.
Right. So it's, so I don't, I mean,
I don't enjoy drinking that much,
and I don't enjoy getting, I mean,
a few drinks and I'm
like, okay, I feel good,
but a few more drinks,
whatever happens after that,
I'm gonna feel so bad
that I just prevent myself
from going there.
Yeah, me too.
I've had like a couple,
I had too much to drink and it wasn't
that I got like embarrassingly drunk, but-
You got sick?
Yeah, it was like I skipped party mode
and all I remember, cause
it wasn't that fulfilling.
And I went straight to
just, I feel like crap mode,
like worst headache,
hangover, even the same night.
Not even the next morning.
Like having a severe reaction, you know
I like to say hydrated.
We know.
So if, yeah, I don't
like drinking too much
because it's just simply not worth it.
Right. But so there's-
I haven't busted my coccyx.
So there's the physical
effects that kind of keep me,
but let's just say that
those didn't exist, right?
Let's just say that there was no hangover
that you had to worry about.
There's still the thing, this
is what I'm trying to get at,
is there a size of a group
and also a familiarity
of a group that it's kind of
like, okay, I'm gonna get drunk
and it doesn't matter
cause I'm with my family,
I'm with my really close friends.
There's nobody who's- I
can't embarrass myself.
But, okay, but there are certain settings
and I think a party with 25
people, we're definitely,
we're in a place where
there's so many people there
that might not even know you.
Or let's just say a work,
a work holiday party,
which is the classic thing for people
to get smashed at a work
holiday party, right?
And you just got to think
about it a little bit.
And you got to think about
it early in the night, right?
You gotta think about early in the night.
I mean, we're not having,
for obvious reasons,
we're not having a party this year.
Yes we are.
Well, we're having a virtual party.
And we are making drinks.
I mean, people can make
their own drink according
to some sort of holiday recipe that-
somebody's got to come
up with that, by the way.
And instead of spending money on a venue,
we spent money on a mythical
outfit for everyone.
Everybody's gonna put
their mythical outfit on
and make drinks.
But especially if you
get a good bartender,
they're gonna make those drinks strong
and you can get like two
drinks in and you can be like,
Oh, okay, another drink and I
may start regretting things.
You really got to have your
radar on for that kind of thing.
And we haven't been in
an environment that much.
I mean, the environment that we grew up in
was like anti-drinking, you know?
And it was, in our
families, it wasn't like we-
We didn't have any relatives
who embarrassed themselves
for getting drunk.
And yeah. And our family get togethers.
My family get togethers there
wasn't alcohol involved.
It's like, I think about
that Robert Earl Keen Christmas song,
the opening line mom got
drunk and dad got drunk
at our Christmas party.
You know that song?
That is a funny song.
Christmas in the family.
What is it? It's very funny.
But it's just culturally
the like different families.
They have different approaches
to like getting inebriated, right?
Some people are like,
you know, if I'm drinking
and I'm not leaving, I'm getting drunk
and I don't care who's here.
That's just some people's mentality.
And you get to get, I mean,
it seems very foreign to think,
getting together with family members
and just three sheets
to the wind, you know?
But I feel like that's the
acceptable place to do it.
It does seem safer.
If you're not leaving
and you know everybody.
Everybody knows you, everybody loves you.
And you can still embarrass yourself.
But it's depends on who you are.
It depends on what you
do when you get drunk.
Some people get mad.
Some people get mad and
want to start a fight yet.
Let's not go there.
I actually think we're going
there a little bit later.
So it's like, I mean, Hecate going
to her brother's ugly
Christmas sweater party,
and just busting her ass.
I mean, you can get hurt.
I mean, that is embarrassing.
Yeah.
It could've been a lot worse though.
Yeah. So I guess-
You could have broke your neck.
What I'm saying is this is something
that can be avoided this
year in most places.
Cause you're probably not
going to have a holiday party.
Don't you- I remember that
there were some parents
when we were in high school
and maybe two sets of parents,
like if you're gonna drink,
we'd rather for you to come over here
and do it at our house.
And of course, you know,
we were in full Baptist mode
around this time, I think.
Well, maybe we had gone
nondenominational, but still,
But we were very much-
But it was from a Baptist
background, which was like-
Don't touch it, don't drink.
If you're gonna drink,
you got to act like you
don't, you got to hide it.
Well, and we thought, and
I don't even know how-
But we judged those families.
We were like, Oh my gosh,
why would a parent allow
their underage drinking
in their home? And it was
like, it was just a, you know?
I don't know. I mean,
I haven't even thought
about this as it pertains
to us as parents.
But I do think that there's
also a legal issue here.
You know, when you are the
adult who is providing the place
for underage kids to drink.
And then some underage kid
is gonna bust their coccyx
and then they're under
your care, technically.
That that could be a problem.
So I do think there is
something to like going
into like a field somewhere
and popping one open versus-
I'm just so surprised in all the times
that we went out camping across the river.
Like, I don't recall
ever, I mean, we made-
We made our own wine.
You made your own wine
and we took it out there and drank it.
But it just felt justified.
Not very much of it.
It felt different. It was
more like a culmination
to a farming process.
It wasn't like a
clandestine let's get drunk.
I mean, there was, we didn't
get anything off of that,
but we didn't like taking any
mad dog or any that stuff out.
We took like chewing
tobacco out there, you know,
which is, which felt different.
But it was technically illegal.
I think we were contributing
to the local economy.
Yeah. Right.
You know, the convenience store clerk,
the farmers on the outskirts of town,
it was easier to justify.
And you're not gonna, the danger
in too much chewing tobacco, at least,
you know, in the short
term, it's pretty low.
Here's what I'll say.
Just moving back to
drinking with your kids.
Let's talk more about that.
Can we talk about drinking with our kids?
No, I mean, I anticipate a
day when the kids are older,
certainly of drinking age and much older.
It's like, even in grandkids territory,
to bring the grandkids over,
we're getting together for the holidays.
It's like, we should be able
to enjoy a bottle of wine together.
When your kids are adults
and have kids? Of course.
But it's not the type of thing that-
I thought you were talking
about drinking with the grandkids.
And I was like, okay, well,
let's talk about that.
Yeah, I was joking, but
when we would go home
for the holidays in previous years,
I mean, it was drinking would
be something that would like,
like if my dad was out there
grilling for like a meal,
we might share a beer, you know?
When I turned 21 and like, me and my dad,
I think there was like
this formative camping trip
that me and my dad went on.
He had a camper and we drank beer together
for the first time.
And it was like a Rite
of passage kind of thing.
But it, culturally, because
of the whole Baptist thing,
drinking wasn't has never been in
and still is not really a part
of any of our family get togethers.
It's just not something that
happens given that situation.
So it actually feels like
what I said when you're like,
of course you can share a bottle of wine
with your family. It's like,
but that wasn't the experience
that I had when I would
visit family, you know?
I mean, you know, my
parents would always have
a little bit of wine.
I mean, if you consider
white Zinfandel a wine,
they might have like a Sutter home,
a little single bottle
of Sutter home, you know.
Growing up and being, you know,
Baptist or non-denominational
like, they, you know,
and I'll enjoy a glass of wine
with dinner every once
in a while kind of thing.
And so even as an adult,
I would still do that.
But again, there's not really,
nobody on either side of our family-
Is getting blitzed.
Is really into like,
I'm gonna make a bunch of
cocktails for everybody.
So there's just that,
that just doesn't exist.
But I mean, there's fun to be had
with a nice cocktail or three,
depending on how you're
spacing it and who's around.
I mean, if you can't have fun
like that with your family,
then who are you gonna have it with?
You're gonna have it
at your brother's house
and you're can break your coccyx.
Yeah. You just got to
know your environment.
I just don't want my kids to grow up
and then them to be totally comfortable
drinking responsibly
and then they come home
and visit me and they feel
like they got to tiptoe around.
That's a strange thing that
is not going to happen,
but it was something that
happened with my family.
I get that. Yeah.
Oh, we're drinking a beer, but
it's out here by the grill.
We're not going to drink one by the table.
I don't think there's any danger of that
being the case in your family.
Moving forward.
Yeah. Right.
But it's an interesting
dynamic still going back home
for Christmas. Like if we went
back next year, it's like,
I bet we would have had
a little bit more fun
with a little bit of, you
know, social lubrication.
And some people just need that just
to get through being with their families.
Yeah, I mean, let's not talk about it
as a coping mechanism.
I'm just saying, for some people...
Well, we could.
Listen, I get it.
Okay. Here we go.
Give me another embarrassing
story. Don't hold back.
This one is from Lena.
She got the name Chia Lincoln.
I'm lit right now, by the way.
I'm just joking.
On water?
chialincoln on Twitter. Wow. Okay.
"We always go for a Christmas Eve meal
at my local restaurant.
It's like a buffet self-serve
thing for my village."
Good luck with that.
"So, one year when I was 13,
I was walking back to my family's table
and tripped on a cable
running across the floor
to power the Christmas
tree lights and fell over."
Moving to the second tweet.
This is a long story.
"Smashing my plate and
food went everywhere.
They cut the Christmas music
to see what was going on."
Was there a record scratch sound effect?
"I was so embarrassed.
I just laid motionless,
pretending I'd passed out
because that seemed like
the least embarrassing thing to do.
My parents still tease me
about it every Christmas."
Lena played possum. They cut the music
and they're looking around
to see what happened
to the lights, and she's
laying face down in the dirt.
Just still.
This is remarkable.
At a certain point, you got to get up.
Yeah. But slowly as if you passed out.
I mean, why does that make it better?
It just makes people more concerned.
Yeah. But it does make it
significantly less embarrassing.
I mean, I got to say-
Oh, you're with this?
Playing possum situation?
Tripping, like, okay.
Do you want people to like
be mocking you with applause?
Like they do at restaurants
when things fall,
or do you want people to be
coming up and being like,
Oh my goodness, are you okay?
We thought you had died.
Now, let me just say,
I would never do this
because I am the King of
trying to play things off,
even if they can't be played off.
So I would try to act
like it was no big deal
and maybe try to like, say
something, but I like this plan.
Just face down, quiet
until someone comes up
and rolls you over.
I mean, just the complex nature
of the emotion of embarrassment.
Can we just have an aside
about that for a second?
You know, you have to know so much
about how your personality
and your culture
and your situation is constructed
so that you you've done something
to screw it up and you feel intense shame.
Is that what it is? It's just like,
I have done something that, you know,
most of the time you feel
embarrassed for things
that it could have been anybody, you know,
everybody's tripped and fallen and like,
stopped the lights, or, you know,
there's been ramifications.
But when it happens to you,
it's as if you're the only
person that's ever happened to.
And it's usually something
you, like you said,
you didn't intend to do.
It's not the spirit of the holidays.
You didn't intend it to go this way.
I think what you're getting at
is it would be very difficult
to make a robot embarrassed.
Like think of the code that
would have to go into an AI
in order to program embarrassment.
And do we want embarrassment
to be a part of the code?
I mean, I think you do, right?
It's hard to trust someone
who can't be embarrassed.
It certainly is admirable
when somebody like just owns
something that normally
would be embarrassing.
Like you stand up and be like, I tripped.
I also didn't think we
needed lights this year.
Or, you know.
Saying something to play it off, for sure.
But I've never thought about it this way,
but wouldn't you find it difficult
to trust someone who
couldn't be embarrassed?
Someone who was literally shameless.
Wouldn't that be? I mean,
either they were so well adjusted and so-
Shameless implies like
doing things on purpose
that most people would be
embarrassed to do by accident.
Well, they didn't have
the ability to have shame
or just didn't have the
ability to be embarrassed,
regardless of what they
said and what they did.
I mean, there are people like that.
My aunt Fey, she was like that.
I think she's passed away.
Fey passed away.
I'm embarrassed to say that, like,
we've lost so many people
on that side of the family
in rapid succession that like,
I think she was one of them,
but we weren't that close.
Every time she said something to me,
it was just like brutally honest.
Cause she had no filter.
She had no filter of if she
was embarrassing anybody
or embarrassing herself. And it was,
I approached her with trepidation.
Right?
Every year at the family
reunion or at the holidays,
at the New Year's Eve thing. It'd be like,
she was the first person
to just come up to me,
to my face and be like, you dye your hair.
She was like, good Lord.
Why do you? You dye your hair, don't you?
Is that why you stopped?
Because of aunt Fey?
It was certainly a factor. It's like, man,
She's exposing my fakeness,
why am I doing this?
This is the last straw.
Maybe you just did it too hard.
I did do it too hard.
Yeah.
It crept up on me.
You got too used to it.
And it's not the type of
person that I wanted to be,
but I didn't want to. And, also,
it doesn't feel good to
be embarrassed by somebody
or to be afraid that
somebody is gonna expose you.
Yeah, because she had the
inability to be embarrassed,
she embarrassed you, she
made it happen in you.
Oh yeah.
This reminds me of Jesse.
My wife had an aunt who
passed away years ago.
Her grandmother's sister.
Oh, you talking about brain woman?
Yeah. She actually had, back in the day,
when lobotomies were a thing.
Now, again, in actual medical history,
the lobotomy was any sort
of surgery on the brain
to address a condition, right?
I don't remember all the things
that she was struggling with,
but it was very significant, right?
And it was affecting her life.
So they did the experimental
surgery that they did
in like the fifties where
they would literally
sever the connection between
the left and the right brain.
This is something that's
been done and is fascinating
to study the people who've
had their two lobes separated
because they can literally be two
different people inside.
It's fascinating to read
the literature on this.
But whatever they did,
when they went in there,
they also got rid of any
impulse to be embarrassed
or self-conscious about anything. And so,
and this happened when she was a teenager.
So she lived her entire
life. Very productive life,
married with kids.
She was a loose cannon?
She was so direct.
Like she was the kind of
person that you go and see her
and you knock on her door
and she'd opened the door
and she'd look at you and she'd be like,
well, you've gained weight, you know?
And some people do that as a jab
and she was just doing
it because she was like,
well, you probably have gained weight.
And she's gonna just tell you.
It the first thing that
came through her brain
and out her mouth.
But I mean, Jesse's
got some great stories,
which I can't remember any of them
for some reason at this moment.
But yeah, she could not be embarrassed,
but you knew that it
was based on something
that had happened to her.
And so there was this
forgiveness that everybody,
this grace that everybody extended to her.
But it's a bit much, right?
So kind of, if you weren't ready for it,
you had to like bolster yourself
to be in her presence probably.
Yeah.
But it was really just a reflection
on any insecurity you may have.
Cause some people are like, man,
I wish I could be like that.
I wish we could all just be blunt
and truthful about everything.
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know. Would we really like that?
And are we even capable?
We're not capable of it.
We're not capable of just getting rid of
whatever it was that
generated the tendency
to be embarrassed about
things. And is probably,
I have to assume, that
if it's part of the code,
it was and continues to
be useful to some degree.
I mean the ability to be
embarrassed about things,
I think is a pretty good social regulator.
I guess, as if the anticipation of it.
Like once you've
experienced embarrassment,
you want to avoid that.
It's like, okay, you don't want
to show any weakness or any stupidity.
It's like, damn, she can't
even walk across a string
of Christmas lights without
bringing down the whole party.
You know? It's like, you
don't want to show yourself
as a liability in any way.
Well, we talked about that.
We've talked about this before, too.
I don't know how we were
coming back to this,
but the fact that a gorilla,
like a Silverback gorilla,
in order to express dominance
over another Silverback,
will get an erection in the
middle of trying to fight.
You keep wanting to talk about it.
No, but I think this is,
because what he's saying
is I'm not scared of you.
I'm not embarrassed at all.
Look what I am capable of.
I'm doing right now. Look,
what's happening right now.
Look at what I'm capable of right now.
Right, yeah. I mean,
gorillas figured it out.
I don't think that's necessarily the path.
I don't think that's the objective.
To walk around with your
testicles everywhere.
I'm just saying that the ability,
in certain circumstances, the ability
to overcome your embarrassment,
there is something to it.
I mean, you could play possum
or you could stand back up
and you could say, you
could just own it and say,
you know what? I tripped.
Has anyone else here ever tripped?
I bet you've all tripped before.
It could have been anybody.
It'd be a nice speech to have prepared.
Any of you people, it could
have been you, not me.
So shut your cake hole.
Stop laughing at me.
That might be more embarrassing
if you, I mean, that
got a little aggressive.
But I do think there is a good
speech that you could have
in your back pocket for
when you embarrass yourself,
physically, in mixed company.
People in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones
or whatever the saying is.
You bunch of hypocrites!
Whenever I feel embarrassed,
I just want to yell at the world.
A bunch of hypocrites!
Try that on.
Cray, Cray fish on Twitter.
"My dad and my brother
got into a fist fight
over Lima beans."
Well, okay. Were they drinking?
"My brother, my sister
and I ended up leaving
and going to the mall."
I'm so intrigued by this,
because first of all,
let me just say, I understand.
I mean, Lima beans are
worth fighting over.
Is it that they both
wanted the Lima beans?
There were some Lima beans
left over because, I mean,
as a bean lover and especially-
It doesn't say get into a
fist fight about Lima beans,
it was over Lima beans.
So it was like they
were, it was under them,
the Lima beans were there, present.
I may be taking it too literally.
I think you're getting it too literal.
I mean, is it a leftover situation
or is this like, you know,
you didn't make enough Lima of beans,
going back for seconds.
To me, this seems other kind
of situation where the brother,
cause a lot of times kids,
they don't really understand
things like you gotta,
you can't just go back and
get seconds or thirds before-
You're literally getting it down.
You're you're making the fight about that.
It could be about so many things.
You think it's about the
recipe of Lima beans?
I'm not gonna weigh in on
the fistfight part of this,
but you know, in any family,
altercations are usually not
about the thing that it
seems like they're about.
It's not really about Lima beans, right?
This is about the son not
meeting the father's expectations
and the son feeling judged.
And you know, I don't know.
I mean, I'm just taking her at her word.
It's about Lima beans. And I just said,
I get how the passion, you know,
can be inflamed by the Lima bean.
It's I know you don't
particularly like Lima beans,
but as someone who does,
I feel like I can speak
as an authority here that they
are a special kind of bean.
They're almost like a
different category of bean.
Cause if you say beans, a lot of times,
people just think of like
baked beans, you know,
think of Pinto beans, something like that.
You kind of need to specify Lima beans.
When you're talking about that,
usually much larger, flat.
Lime flavored bean.
Green, you know, brownish.
And if you do it right,
there was some ham hock there
and maybe some fat back.
I mean, that's.
You talking about a butter bean now you.
That's how you do Lima beans as well.
Lima bean is basically
just a big butter bean.
Yitzey Raven shared,
"When my sister was much younger,
she by mistake lit her hair on
fire by the Hanukkah menorah.
We tell this story year to year to year,
fast forward to last
year. And her daughter,
my niece, did the exact same thing."
Caught her hair on fire!
"My brother just said,
just like your mommy.
Hashtag like mother, like daughter."
Man, you talk about an exciting Christmas.
Somebody getting their hair
caught on fire. That'll do it.
I mean, how many-
I guess this is not
Christmas. This is Hanukkah.
How many menorahs today
are still like literal fire, right?
The fun ones.
But I think a lot of this
has been replaced with,
Oh, there's an electric one.
Flame bulbs, the bulbs
that look like flames.
That don't move. I never
fall for that, by the way.
I've never once fallen for
a bulb shaped like a flame.
And I thought that, wow,
they're actually burning the candle.
I've never fallen for
that. I'm proud of that.
Have you ever, there's some in restaurants
that I think you would fall for.
Oh, they flicker?
Yeah.
They dance a little bit?
They've got a thing in there
that's spinning at an irregular rate
that actually makes it
look like it's a flame.
Now when you get on top of it,
you see, Oh, that's not
what's happening here.
Okay. Well, when I'm on top
of it, I wouldn't fall for it.
Right, but if you just see it,
like if you see it from a profile
or you see it from a distance.
Okay. Maybe I've fallen for it.
I'm not gonna say I've
never fallen for it.
Boy. I mean, how many flames
on the menorah? Eight?
Well, it seems like there
would be an odd number.
I'm gonna think there's 12.
Is there one in the middle?
Yeah, there's one in the middle.
We're starting to whisper
cause we really don't know.
All I know is there's a lot
of potential for flames here.
I think it's 13.
No, there's not that many.
Oh gosh. We got to look this up. How many-
You know, as a former Baptist, the closest
that we get to starting a
fire during the holidays-
and we were right, there's nine.
Yeah, nine is not a
number that we had said.
Is the advent candles.
And what we would do, did
they do this in your church?
So you had the advent candles
that during the advent season,
they, you know, you start
lighting different candles
and you bring up a different
family with their kids.
Yeah.
Kids are often, depending
on what age they are,
the kids are sometimes given-
A script.
Well, not only a script,
but sometimes they get
to light the candles.
They let the families decide,
sometimes just like the dad
goes in there and he's like,
listen, I'm the dad, I'm
gonna light the candle.
Yeah.
And then sometimes it's like, well,
we're gonna let little Suzie do it.
Nothing shows nerves more than having
to light a candle like that.
You go a whole church,
You got to push on the thing,
then you got to pull the trigger.
And you might get a weak one, sometimes.
Especially if you're in
one of the later weeks,
like when they've really used
that lighter a few times.
You're using two forms
of pressure on one hand
and you're in front of people.
And you're holding your kid.
You're shaking, too, probably.
You're not used to getting
up in front of the church.
And so it doesn't matter
that these people,
everybody's pulling for you.
No one, I mean, people judge
you when you get up there,
that's what people do. But
everybody's pulling for you.
And maybe this is a
relatively small church.
Maybe there's 120 people,
but you still have this flash,
speaking of embarrassment,
You can't get the advent candle lit,
you're immediately embarrassed.
And then there's the like,
am I gonna say something?
Am I gonna make a joke?
Is somebody gonna come up
to help me light this thing?
Should I fall flat on my face
and act like I've passed out?
This is a scenario in which
my dad was really good
as a person in the actual congregation
of saying something to
make everybody laugh.
He'd yell from the pew?
Yeah.
Stupid Stan, you can't light a candle!
No, he'll say something.
Like, I told him to get
a new lighter, you know,
he'll say something that
takes the pressure off
of the person and then
makes everybody laugh.
And then the guy will like,
be like, yeah, that's right.
And then they'll go back to keep doing it.
Jesus turned water into wine,
let's see if he can light up that candle.
It's usually not. That's not
a good plan to invoke that.
But that's the closest we
can get to starting a fire.
And I'm sure there's been
some serious advent fires.
Well, if you leave them burning all week,
which that I hate to burst your bubble,
but like a trigger
warning, put the kids away.
If they're listening, send them away.
They don't leave the advent
candles burning all week.
You have to relight them.
I bet you, they do, at
like the Catholic church
they burn them all the time.
The further you go, if
you're a later family,
you have to relight all
those other candles.
Oh yeah.
So there's lots of stuff
to light. What a nightmare.
Lady Buffberry tweeted,
"My Nana bought my husband
and I sexy matching lingerie."
First of all, I have several
questions about this.
The least of them is your
grandmother did this.
What does the man wear to
match with a woman's lingerie?
Have you ever worn anything like this?
I've never had matching
lingerie with my wife, no.
I've never actually seen that.
I mean, I mean, I, this is.
I'm sure this is sexist,
I've never really thought
about in a lingerie
situation, what I was doing.
I've never thought, what
should I have on right now?
I've had some underwear that
I would never wear otherwise.
I tried that a few times.
What? Like what? Edible?
No,
like special, sexy briefs.
Really?
Yeah, I think I still have a pair buried
in my drawer somewhere.
Is it a thong?
No, it's not. The cheeks weren't out.
But it was, it was just more of-
Not boxer briefs.
It was just a different kind of brief.
Not whitey tighteys, they
were like red or something.
They were made out of
a different material.
Like a smoother material.
I think we might be getting closer
to what nana was thinking when she bought.
Maybe it was like, I got
you a little black teddy
and I got him a black thong.
You know what I'm saying?
So maybe it didn't come in
a set, maybe it was just-
That's what she was getting at.
Okay. Well, I didn't know about that.
How would you? How would you?
I'm not saying, I didn't
know about you doing that.
Yeah. I didn't, I didn't know.
I haven't thought about
that aspect of it for me.
But now I am.
You know, just something a little fun,
something a little fun.
It's like a form fitting type thing.
Now it's not for everyday use, you know,
it's just a little novelty.
I mean, it's like all the sexy lingerie,
I guess there's people who
like, wear that stuff every day.
Like the real sexy stuff,
like the lacy stuff?
But I don't, I mean, unless
you're like a dominatrix,
I don't think that's something
you wear all the time.
Okay.
That's your job.
I think that these are
just like matching boxers
and like a teddy.
I don't think this is like
super lacy thong situation.
But, okay now, let's get to the fact
that your grandmother did it.
She knows how this works.
I know what y'all are doing.
You know, it's not a surprise to me.
Right.
So I fully endorse this.
I think more grandma
should give sexy lingerie.
And now that I know that
there's matching lingerie,
I think more of them should give that.
Talk about the first time
that Christy came over
to visit like my Nana and like,
all the Neals were together for dinner.
After dinner, Nana was like,
we should all get a picture.
You know, everything was
going so great with Christy.
They were getting to know
her for the first time,
they loved her accent.
"She's one of us," they
said, Nana was like, well,
let's get a picture.
And then we all got together.
And then as they were
ready to take the picture,
she said, "All right, on
three, everybody say 'sex'!"
You know? So at a certain
age, you're like, listen,
let's just get over this. I mean,
we didn't drink at the table,
but we would say sex when
you're taking a picture, boy.
This happened more than once?
Like that was her go-to?
Actually, no,
that was the only time I'd
ever heard her say that.
How did people react?
Everybody laughed and
the picture was taken
and it was perfect.
Yeah. I can see Nana, and
that's her name as well,
I could see Nana doing
this almost as a joke,
but also doing it seriously.
Oh Yeah.
Live it up. Enjoy each other.
She hasn't done the sex
picture thing since?
Yeah, it was never before, never after.
She pulled it out at the perfect time.
Kind of like that guy beside your Tesla.
Okay. Last one from Zack Stroud.
"When I was a kid, I wanted people to know
I appreciated it when they
gifted me clothes for Christmas.
So to give the appearance of,
'I really care about this gift
and don't want to toss it aside
like most gifted clothes,'
I would sniff them. Not sure
why went on for a few years."
Well, Zack, I definitely understand
the hyper-awareness of
when you open the gift.
That's the moment of the
gifter to feel joy, you know?
To be brimming with satisfaction of yes,
the thing that I got weeks
ago and wrapped lovingly,
I'm seeing them open it
right before my eyes.
And look, they're happy about it,
even though they're a
child and it's a shirt,
he still seems happy about
it. In fact, he's sniffing it.
Yeah. Nothing feels like
a better endorsement
than sniffing something.
I understand that the principal,
I would probably have stopped
short from actually sniffing.
I probably would have hugged it
and like maybe felt it against my face.
And then I could see
how that might actually
get your wires crossed and all of a sudden
you're sniffing a polo shirt.
Well, and I think it's
all about what you do
after you sniff it.
Because I imagine Zack is
like sniffing it, like,
and then kind of looking at the gifter
and just like just kinda
nodding and smiling.
It does really convey cherish.
You know my heart,
If you pull something to your nose,
that's an intimate place, you
know, the front of your face.
Yeah, because if you serve somebody food
and they smell it and savor it.
Zack, I actually think
you're onto something.
I think that we could apply
this to more things in life.
Anything that where, you know,
that someone is watching you
to get a sense of validation.
It's like just incorporate a
long, like a thoughtful sniff.
I think this could be done
in like legal documents,
like the exchange of a document.
So like, if you go through that process
of when you buy a home,
you have to sign like 40
different things, you know?
What, if you would not only
sign them, but sniff them?
This is making me think of our-
Smell it, but come up big.
Smell it but come up big signature.
It's like, you do your autograph.
See, you're talking about signature.
Oh, wow. Somehow those two converged.
But we said that if
you sign your autograph
and you can come up big.
You smell it and come up big.
But do you smell it?
I think so.
I think there was a smell
and then come up big.
I don't remember.
This is a moment, if you don't remember,
it happened on Good Mythical Morning.
It was one of those silly Moores
where things just got off the rails.
We were talking about
what's the weirdest thing
you've ever signed on someone's body,
and we talked about how NASCAR
drivers would sign boobies.
And then somehow we
were talking about like,
sign it and come up big.
There was no sniffing?
I don't think there was sniffing involved.
But now there should be sniffing involved.
Not if it's boobies.
I know, I'm talking
about just for documents.
Well, again, that's a
signature, not an autograph.
I just think every gift
should be breathed in deeply.
I think it's a great way
to convey cherishment.
Appreciation.
Yeah, that's the word I'm looking for.
So nothing to be ashamed of here, Zack.
You should just do it again.
You should start doing it again. Yeah.
Sniffing clothes. I
mean, I have this sense
of everybody's watching
me open these gifts
and I don't want anybody's
feelings to be hurt.
So what I would do when I got clothes
and I would be thinking,
I need to compensate
for not being excited about this as a kid,
I would immediately put the clothes on.
Like, if it was a shirt,
I'll put the shirt on
over my existing shirt.
I was like, nothing says that I'm willing
to wear this shirt you got me more
than actually wearing the
shirt you got me right now.
Wow. You did that.
I would do that.
If it was a shirt or a
sweater or a pullover,
if it were pants, when
all the gifts were given,
I might sneak away, try on the
pants and come back and say,
Hey, I tried on the pants you got me.
Cause there's a question. Does it fit?
Is it gonna, you know, do you like them?
Oh, look, I'm already
in the pants you got me.
Isn't this great? And
they would feel relief.
What if it was one of
those little black thongs
from your Nana?
I'd wait on that. Again,
they weren't thongs,
the cheeks weren't out.
Okay. A little tight fitting briefs.
Let's call it a banana hammock.
A banana hammock. Yeah.
A budded banana hammock.
Would you try that on
for any of your Nana?
No. I would not. I have not. I shall not.
I don't want to, she doesn't want me to,
no one wants me to, except
you. And I'm not going to.
I don't want you to.
Do you think that people are gonna try
to find a way to do like zoom gifting?
I haven't even thought about this.
Mailed a gift and then
wait to open it on zoom.
Open it on zoom.
I think we haven't thought
about that. We should do that.
Sniffing is a really, really
good thing in that context,
because there's only so many
things you can say or do,
but you can definitely
bring whatever gift it is
up into your frame and sniff it.
Well, I actually feel
more ready looking back
on this conversation for my next moment
of being embarrassed.
I feel like I've bolstered
my loins a little bit
and I'm ready to not be as embarrassed
when something embarrassing happens
to me during the holidays,
I'm gonna own it.
When.
Yeah, when. I'm gonna
put it back on people.
I got a recommendation,
if you're open for it.
I'm open for it, into it.
Rec baby rec baby. One, two, three, four.
Me and Christy and Lando watched something
and we were all into it.
If you got a kid on the younger side,
ten-ish like Lando, I think the older kids
would have been into this,
but they didn't watch it.
It's an Apple TV series,
docu-series called Becoming You.
We just needed something to watch.
All the stuff that we watch as a family,
if one of the family members isn't there,
you can't watch it. So it's
just a little filler thing.
Just take it to fill
in a gap in your life.
But it's kids from around the globe
and they've documented their
first 2000 days on earth.
"Told through the eyes of 100
children across the world,
from Nepal to Japan, to Borneo,
each episode offers a
thought provoking look
at how children learn to think, speak,
and move from birth to age five.
It underscores how different
our journeys can be,
but ultimately tells the
story of our shared humanity
and community when it
comes to raising children."
You got these cute kids that
you're not responsible for.
And it is fascinating how they present it.
They talked about, there was
this one kid who was, I swear,
he was only three years
old, this kid in Tokyo.
And I know you don't say that.
I don't do that on Ear Biscuits.
You don't do that on Ear Biscuits.
You only do it on the show,
but there's this thing
called my first errand.
And it's like a Rite of passage for kids.
As young as three years
old could be like six
or seven years old.
And the kid goes out on his own errand
and they documented it on
this, on the first episode.
And they say, all right,
you need to go pick up so-and-so
from the grocery store.
I love this.
And then this kid is three years old
and he's walking around Tokyo,
like using public transportation,
going to the bodega.
Oh my goodness.
Like, the cameras weren't too hidden.
Cause they like filmed the
interaction with the bodega.
And he's like, you have money?
And the parents?
Like this is a Japanese tradition.
The parents are not there. The
parents do not follow them.
This will be controversial in America.
And they come back. The kids comes back
with an understanding of
a new level of capability.
At three?
As young as three.
That's how old this kid was. And yeah,
and it's a Rite of passage
in Japanese culture
called my first errand. And in fact,
there's a television show in Japan
where they have hidden cameras
and they document kids doing
this, their first errand.
So it's like something that
like everybody knows about.
You'll see like a three-year-old kid,
just walking along the cross walk.
We don't say, "Are you
looking for your mom?"
And he's like, no,
"I'm getting a pack of
cigarettes for my granddad."
They all assume that that's
what's happening. Yeah.
Then this television show,
I would love to watch it.
"Hajimete No Otsukai,"
or "My First Errand"
has been running for more than 25 years.
Oh my goodness. This is a thing.
Isn't that so cool?
So that was just a little
part of episode one, but,
and they skipped between all these kids
to like show the development process
and it's very heartwarming
and you learn some stuff.
I didn't know about My First Errand.
And it was too late for our kids, now.
25 years that show's
been running over there.
I mean, in America, you get arrested
for letting your kids go to the playground
without you being there.
I mean, there was like.
Well, and I've never been
to Tokyo, but I mean,
in this one article I
was reading, they were-
It's culturally different.
It's different.
Like those parents would say,
I would never set my kid
loose in New York city
or somewhere else to
do their first errand.
Yeah. If it was a
culturally accepted thing,
super low crime, that kind of thing,
then it's a different thing. Oh, wow.
So I've only watched episode
one, watched it last night,
but you know, I recommend it.
It's pretty cool.
Okay, I'll think about watching it
now that you recommended it.
Yeah, that's all I ask. Think about it.
And you know what, next time you're
in an embarrassing situation,
just do what that guy
did next to your Tesla
and just shake it off.
I've been sitting on that one.
Okay. So, is next week the
last episode of this season?
Yeah.
Am I right about that?
Okay, yes.
We're doing our top 10.
Yeah, fair warning, we're
each doing our top 10 of 2020,
like we've been doing for
the past couple of years
and that'll be the last episode of 2020.
And we'll come back, not
too far into the new year
with the next season.
I've got to start working on my list.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.